[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein
grundrezept vor mir und zwar zeige ich
euch das grundrezept für vanille und
schoko muffins
ich habe für mich die perfekten
mengenangaben herausgefunden um richtig
lockere und leckere muffins zu erhalten
hier zeige ich euch die
standardvarianten schokolade und vanille
ihr könnt die aber auch ganz einfach
abwandeln für die vanille muffins
benötigen wir mehl zucker weiche butter
zimmer war mayer außerdem lauwarme milch
etwas backpulver ein wenig vanillezucker
und eine prise salz zuallererst wird die
butter zusammen mit dem zucker dem
vanillezucker und der prise salz gemixt
für das mixen könnt ihr entweder eure
küchenmaschine nehmen oder ein
handrührgerät ich zeig euch heute die
zubereitung mit einem handrührgerät
[Musik]
zirka zwei minuten wird das ganze jetzt
schön durch gemixt und dann geht es
weiter mit den eiern die geschwindigkeit
verringern ich jetzt ein wenig und gäbe
dann nach und nach die eier mit hinzu
und es ist wichtig dass die eier
zimmertemperatur haben damit sie sich
gut für den restlichen teig verbinden
[Musik]
hier kann man ganz gut erkennen wie
schön cremig das ganze geworden ist und
jetzt geben wir abwechselnd mit der
milch die trockenen zutaten mit hinzu
damit auch keine klümpchen entstehen sie
sich das noch einmal durch und gäbe dass
dann in die masse hier ist es ganz
wichtig dass ihr abwechselnd arbeitet
also gebt erstmal ein wenig von den
trockenen zutaten nein rührt das ganze
schön um und dann immer wieder ein
schlückchen von der lauwarme milch mit
hinzugeben so könnt ihr garantieren dass
euer tag wirklich perfekt wird
[Musik]
für das machen rezept ist es ganz
wichtig dass die milch lauwarm ist und
die eier sowie die butter
zimmertemperatur haben falls sie eines
der zutaten nämlich direkt aus dem
kühlschrank holt und weiterverarbeitet
dann wird euer tag kompakt und erzielt
nicht die gewünschten ergebnisse
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann abwechselnd die zutaten
mit den zugegeben habt ist euer muffin
teig auch schon fertig und sollte sofort
weiterverarbeitet werden
ich habe mir meinen muffin blech mit
mein muffin förmchen schon bereitgelegt
ein ofen ist ebenfalls vorgeheizt und
jetzt nehme ich mir zu hilfe diesen ice
portionierer nun werden die förmchen
gefüllt und zwar jeweils drei viertel
hoch denn das rezept reicht genau für
zwölf muffins
[Musik]
übrigens hier ein kleiner tipp falls ihr
statt der vanille muffins lieber
zitronen muffins backen möchtet dann
ersetzt den vanillezucker einfach durch
zitronenschale oder zitronensaft
die muffins werden jetzt bei 180 grad
ober und unterhitze für 22 minuten
gebacken für die schokoladen muffins
gebe ich wieder butter zucker die prise
salz und das vanille in dem fall nämlich
von den extrakt aber ihr könnt natürlich
auch von den zucker nehmen in meine
rührschüssel und rühre das schön glatt
der einzige unterschied liegt bei den
trockenen zutaten hier ersetzen wir ein
teil des mehls durch cacau nachdem also
die butter zucker mischung cremig
aufgeschlagen wurde
geben wir nach und nach die zimmer war
mayer mit hinein
anschließend werden die trockenen
zutaten gesiebt und abwechselnd mit der
lauwarmen milch in den teig verarbeitet
auch hier noch mal ganz kurz der hinweis
dass es wirklich wichtig ist dass ihr
das ganze ab wechselt macht und nicht
erst die kompletten trockenen zutaten
hinzu gibt und dann die milch ihr werdet
den unterschied auf jeden fall merken
[Musik]
nachdem der teig dann auch vorbereitet
wurde können wir ihnen unsere muffin
förmchen geben und backen
[Musik]
falls ihr ein wenig abwechslung möchtet
dann könnt ihr in den teig gerne noch
ein paar schoko drops geben auch eine
schöne idee ist wenn ihr einen halben
riegel im teig versteckt und mit backt
und dann habt ihr ein richtig schön
überraschungs kern meine schoko muffins
habe ich ebenfalls weiter verarbeitet
und das ergebnis seht ihr dann in meinem
nächsten video die muffins werden dann
ebenfalls für 22 minuten im backofen
gebacken
so sehen die fertigen muffins nun aus
und können nach herzenslust dekoriert
werden
[Musik]
für mich sind es die leckersten und
lockersten marines überhaupt falls ihr
das ganze mal austesten möchte dann
schaut gern mal unternehmen die infobox
dort habe ich für euch alle genauen
mengenangaben noch einmal aufgeschrieben
[Musik]
in den nächsten wochen zeige ich euch
dann was ich alles aus diesem grund
rezept gezaubert habe das nächste rezept
erscheint schon in zwei tagen also
abonniert auf jeden fall meinen kanal
damit ihr auch erfahrt was für leckere
cupcakes draus geworden sind ich danke
euch für das einschalten wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß zum nachbacken und sagt
bis zum nächsten mal auf klischees
kitchen